always announce it here first my road
dates because you guys are my engaged
listeners and that's what makes sense
and you're gonna come see me in the next
couple of weeks i am in vegas july 15th
at the brand new virgin hotel uh july
16th at the celebrity theater in phoenix
arizona and then in boulder colorado on
the 17th
at the boulder theater the following
week or actually the following few days
later july 20th i'm in portland at the
arlene schnitzer concert hall i haven't
been to portland in a minute i love you
guys you're always asking me to come i'm
there tell a friend as well if you hear
this city tell your friend they don't
want to miss me i promise you seattle
washington on july 21st the paramount
theater the vogue theater in vancouver
my first ever canadian solo date on july
22nd
i'll be at in canada a few months from
now again in hamilton and toronto in
october and then there's a bunch of new
dates that were just announced for the
fall really quickly it's richmond
virginia hershey pa knoxville tennessee
atlanta birmingham louisville evansville
jacksonville tampa orlando sacramento
san jose and santa rosa those are all on
sale right now and they're all not
coming until the fall so you can get
those tickets
right away they're the good tickets and
i'll see you guys in july i appreciate
you guys come laugh and uh i'm just i'm
just now i'm just vamping because joe's
gonna do his dates next and we might cut
out of this and cut into it
all right so there was no reason for me
to vamp
okay so then there was no reason for you
to listen to the last 20 seconds of this
hey baby go to
chrisdcomedy.com i am in montreal at the
end of july i am in burlington vermont
and i got bray improv in august and we
got san francisco in september and we
got chicago theater in september we got
more dates coming soon but montreal and
vermont on sale now july 27th and 29th
chrisdcomedy.com for tiki wiki's also my
special
out on netflix
[Music]
in a minute i'm gonna need a sentimental
man or woman to pump me up feeling fussy
walking in my valencia trying to figure
out the fab you lust cause i give a [ __ ]
way too much i'm gonna need like hey
baby my cup want to get up want to get
down that i don't know the rest of it
hey babe hey babe hey what the hell was
that i don't know i hear it all the time
now oh
yes well we still we tried
those lizzo thong remember the thongs
the lizzo with her ass out
yeah the anseless pants yeah we were
trying to order them oh we're gonna do
an episode of hey
get them
everywhere
um are you going to go anywhere on
summer vacay
so
now
you're not a summer vacation i wanted to
winter vacation i know what i like to do
i like to rent a little i like to do a
getaway up in the mountains up in the
lakes for the i like to rent a
airbnb for a week in the summer okay i
mean when i was little i never went on
vacation i was 18 years old when i was
little i always thought in my head you
go on a vacation in the summer and then
people would tell me you're lunatic it's
hot here in the summer you stay here in
the summer you go on vacation in the
winter see i'm a winter chaser i want to
chase fall in winter so i
like i want to go see cities in europe
let's say in the fall and winter i don't
want to see them in the summer i don't
give a rat's ass
about about italy in the summer right i
don't care about italy in the summer
i want italy in the fall and winter okay
i
couldn't i would give my left [ __ ]
nut okay
to go see
germany in the winter who gives you so
why don't you do it about summer germany
so then when you when you talk to me
about summer vacay
isn't that what you mean though then why
you because people like people get away
to go too warm so they'll so the theory
is why are you leaving here in the
summer when it's already warm to go to
warm i'll go to work
in their winter
i'll go to australia for july and also i
went to australia in
no yeah i went in november
no listen i would love to go away but
i'm too busy
i'm too bizarro you're you're bizarre
you're a busy body yeah some people are
busy bees you're a busy real yeah you're
a kangaroo of busyness
i think um i what i'm gonna do this year
see this last year
i said this december last december i
said this december 2022 i'm going to go
to a german christmas market for
christmas instead i booked a tour in the
south in charleston south carolina and
uh and and north carolina i'm gonna be
north carolina south carolina in
december but i'm thinking i'm thinking
just for a few days maybe even after
christmas maybe even that time that
funny little time yeah from december 26
to january 1st i think maybe then i'll
go yeah i'll watch them taking the
christmas markets down oh
i can't go anywhere in december why not
because i refuse to miss the december to
remember sales event he won't do it i
won't do it doesn't mean december to
remember salesman go internationally at
this point
pimp
it's december what is that i want to go
there that's the chris that's a
rotten bird christmas village right here
bottom left bottom left what is that
sir tsunergia surnagia
festive christmas markets
god
berlin
frankfurt or munich these are the
christmas villages man i want to grow i
want to go on a christmas village tour
that's what i want to do i'll do it
together let's do it you want to do
christmas i want to do it i really want
you but american christmas villagers you
want to go to germany that's where they
invest
i want to go to the alps or whatever i
want to go to where it looks like a snow
globe i talked to you about this yeah i
want to go i want to go where it looks
like a
painting dude like an old an old uh
what's that guy's name from the
morning van gogh no like from the he he
painted all the the
the he captured like murder
americana no no he owned a saturday
morning post
come on baby you know peter vesey no no
you know this guy big time guy he's a
gun guy he's a painter he did all the
covers of the saturday morning post i
think it's called the uh uh come on
rockwell norman rockwell norman rockwell
i want to go to where it looks like like
like a straight up christmas norman
rockwell you know what i'm saying so
yeah so also what i think we need to do
is we need to just go on literally like
this got to be spur of the moment what i
want to do is a spur of the moment
vacation just me and you like i'm
talking about we're sitting here it's
let's say mid-january we're sitting here
we got a free weekend you all have set
up a free weekend i will send a free
weekend book an immediate trip to
iceland we go right to reykjavik we go
see the northern lights i'm talking
about you can't think about it i want to
do a thing where i call you i say sal
i'm down since you've got 20 minutes to
pack get in the
wow that's living life isn't that fun
but nobody does that nobody does it but
you got to do it at least i don't know
but i can't but you can't how can you do
it if you don't have kids you got a
family
you can't do it wow look at that is that
it
that's nice
you think that's a filter
you think it looks like that no no i
think that it looks like that there's
certain places that you go that that it
looks like that wow i would love to see
it
uh if if the north pole existed right
would you be fascinated with the north
pole existing well san francisco
and santa's real yeah okay so so
would you
if you had the chance would you go up to
the north pole and like vacation there
and or check out the like the factory
like the north pole like the santa's
stuff and would you like if they had
internships or something would you do
that i think that i would give up a
month of my life to go work at the poll
i would do it i'd work at the poll yeah
right i'd work i would
work with with chrisanna yeah and the
elves i would do that [ __ ] i'd i you
know what i'd say should there'd be a
waiting list for that that you can never
get into it you can never get on i'd
work at like the city md i'd be like the
physical therapist
in the north pole you go look for oh you
i'd help out any injured elf yeah i'd
help because i used to be a pediatric
physical therapist so i know how to work
on little body parts i know how to
stretch them out if nobody was looking
and you know that the elf wouldn't get
hurt
would you would you like would you kick
an elf yeah yeah because i think that's
well no one's looking and the elf
doesn't get hurt because they're two big
things i heard that that's that's really
the only true true true way to stop
hiccups is to kick an elf down the
stairs is that right yep that's the only
way a lot of people say if you got the
hiccups you find an elf you kick them
down the stairs
and your hiccups stop same way to stop
uh an itch in the back of the throat you
know my cannon you know my cat and
friend of the show mike cannon told me
two days ago that he's had an itch in
the back of his throat that he has not
been able to scratch for three weeks i
was like how are you even living he was
like i'm i'm getting to the point i'm
going to get violently i'm getting
violently depressed i was like yeah dude
he goes literally for the last 21 days
every second of my waking life oh no the
back of my throat is itchy no he goes
i've taken claritin i've done everything
i would i would literally stick a knife
back there well he said he said he had
his little three-year-old put his son
put his little three-year-old hand in
the back and try to itch his throat and
instead he just vomited all over him no
yeah mike has no gag reflex
hey mike call me what causes an itch
in the back of the throat no
but sure
oh you're saying what causes an itch no
idea right do we know that
do we not know what causes an egg let's
find out what causes an itch from my
cannon it's blondes definitely my cannon
it's blunt yeah what causes an itch well
that scratches his itch
what causes it no not even the back of
the throat but let's do backwards and
why does scratching it make it feel
better i don't know what an itch is how
about that
i don't really know what it is it's
gotta be some type of nerve neural
sensation that's like hyper-excitable
right
what is
what is what causes just an itch pimp
not backing through get back of the
throat out let's get it let's get into
some d for hey babe after dark
no but what
what is this science what isn't it
that's what it is and why is it called
an itch by the way itch does sound like
a half of a word it sounds like you like
a [ __ ] without the b oh i'm sorry i'll
stay here i'm trying to keep you yeah
i'm here itchy skin but what is an
actual itch
where is the itch and why does it move
what is an itch
receptors see nerve cells on specialized
nerve cells translate that alarm message
into itch
then specialize nerve fibers
speed the itch signal to the signal cord
to the spinal cord to propel it onward
to the brain the brain instantly deploys
fingernails back to the itch site where
the friction from nails on skin unseats
the invader so you have an invader on
your cells
and then you scratch it and the invader
falls off your cells
when you take your fingernails and
scratch the surface of your skin you're
temporarily damaging the receptors which
cause your brain to send pain relieving
chemicals to the area
one such natural chemical is serotonin
but so so it's it's nerve but why is it
happening
why it's saying because you damage your
receptors you damage the receptors in
your skin
how when how
do i have an injury
no i don't i don't know like like you
know sounds like malarkey well like i
told you what dancing is i told you this
once on your body doesn't know it
doesn't know what to do it gets so
overstimulated it just starts to dance
the nerves are acting wacky that's the
scientific uh
synopsis there check this out uh
scratching doesn't make the itch go away
in fact over the long run it can make
people even more sensitive to itchy
sensations repeated damage to the skin
makes it grow thicker and sprout even
more itched nerves that's what they say
don't it like if you itch like a
mosquito bite i guess it spreads it
makes worse right
yeah itching
what sensation
do you think like would make you want to
commit suicide the quickest like if you
couldn't get rid of it would it be an
itch would it be a sore throat would it
oh i hate a sore throat would it be a
twitchy eye
would it be a sneeze you can't get out
would it be a um
a swollen taste bud
would it be
um
would it be a a nagging cough
you have to deal with this for 15 years
let's say which one a sore throat
you take the sore throat for 15 years or
you kill yourself
off
i couldn't do it off with your head
which would get ready you couldn't do it
at all one time when i was in
kindergarten this girl started sneezing
maybe first grade something she started
sneezing and then she didn't stop
she wouldn't stop sneezing she didn't
she couldn't stop i couldn't believe it
she didn't stop she was sneezing she
kept sneezing she kept sneezing the
teacher was like okay teacher was like
are you okay she kept sneezing they went
and got someone they came up she kept
sneezing she kept sneezing they took her
out she was sneezing so they call her
parents her parents came and got her she
was sneezing sneezing she left sneezing
i i watched you ever see her again
i mean i i yes
okay yes so i want to make sure she's
still nice she didn't die but she i i
never see anything like it
you know when you sneeze like two times
in a row three times in a row she did
that for like one hour
can you imagine could you imagine how
does she breathe i don't know also
doesn't your heart stop when you sneeze
or is that a fabe
i don't know you all they say like an
angel if an angel's crossing over
while you sneeze your heart can stop or
something like that i don't i don't when
you sneeze everything stops
when you sneeze the intro intrathoracic
pressure in your body momentarily
increases this will decrease the blood
flow back to the heart
the heart compensates for this by
changing its regular heartbeat
momentarily to adjust however the
electrical activity of the heart does
not stop during the season do you know
that there's electrolyte you probably
know that because you're you're a
physical factor there's electricity in
the heart yeah yeah well that's why it's
very interesting like electricity like
the discovery of electricity like with
ben franklin and thomas edison all that
like we've had electricity in our bodies
since we were neanderthals right right
right so it's like it's pretty wild it's
pretty wild at like electricity it's
like something from like the gods of the
universe you know what i mean um do you
know twins i was watching this thing
about twins you know like
uh there's like things that they don't
understand about like uh uh not
fraternal twins identical twins like
identical twins they share they believe
that it's like two souls one body like
whatever you know when you say soul
science can't really explain that yet
but there's this phenomenon that happens
with twins like there were these two
twins that were separated at birth
um and they lived like a hundred miles
away from each other but when they met
up when they were like in their 60s they
had the same color car they had the dog
they named their dog the same thing they
vacationed on the same three-mile
stretch of land they uh wives i think
were that had the same name with the
same hairstyle they named their children
the same it's like nuts like google
pimp google twins
both name their dog toy
twins that both name their dog toy
oh and then go back to this article
because that was interesting jim lewis
had a brother larry and a dog called toy
yeah so scroll down a little bit i don't
know if this might be it this yeah these
are the guys uh identical twin brothers
were separated at birth you can win one
in 500 gift vouchers
that just popped up
at three weeks their adoptive parents
called their new sons james or jim for
short um
jim lewis had a brother larry and a dog
called toy wait hold on okay
uh jim so jim jim
jim and larry were brothers identical
twin brothers that were separated at
birth okay
jim had a dog named toy larry had a dog
named wow
um
jim enjoyed math and woodwork but had a
strong dislike for spelling so did his
brother
uh jim they both married a woman named
betty yeah they both were chain smokers
and both set from migraines and bolts
over blue chevrolet and they both had a
son named james allen and they both
worked as a deputy sheriff and bolted
their son's name was james allen at the
age of 39 their pass finally crossed for
the first time after jim lewis
discovered the contact details of
identical twin it didn't take long for
the similarities and their life stories
to unravel so that is irrevocable
evidence irrefutable evidence that it's
two souls one bod that is
yup dr bouchard said he was left
flabbergasted flabbergasted which which
is a word you don't hear nearly enough
anymore yeah flabbergasted is a
fantastic because i want to say like
when you'd say now like oh i was shocked
really no i was flabbergasted yeah okay
i was flummoxed i was flummoxed i was
flabbergasted laying down in my
vestibule can you
keep this page but can you go to is
flabbergasted the only
tents of flabbergasted
you have flabbergasted i was
flabbergasted
no i don't think that's right i was
saying flabbergasted is the only word
that you can only be flabbergasted well
is is that past tense or i was
flabbergasted to learn
uh i was flabbergasted to learn that i
was flabbergasted to learn but you were
flabbergasted to learn
no you are a guest you were not you were
i am flabbergasted to learn
right because if you were flabbergasted
to learn weren't weren't you
flabbergasted because it's in the past
you were worries are past tense right
yes so if you were
flabbergasted
you are flabbergasted exactly
exactly
flabbering gas
it's what it is
flabbergasted
i can't read any of it
yeah so
how wild is that about twins my father
oh flabbergasting so you ready for this
my father
is a fraternal twin not an identical his
twin was a woman do you realize that my
father for 48 years of his life had a
woman that kind of looked like him on
this planet
it's like wild when you think of my dad
kind of nuts but she passed away when
they were 48 or 49 years old
and he said that when she you know she
was sick in the hospital and he always
felt like you know that she was you know
you know uh you know sick and it's sad
to see your sister or twin dying
whatever but always felt like
you know sad but like not like this
insane
feeling of dread he said when she died
like you know he found she died i
believe in the middle of the night but
he said he woke up in the middle of the
night with unbelievable dread he said no
pain
no nothing like just a sense of full
dread like where he was like something's
going on he said that he actually called
my mother's house and was like is
everything okay with christopher because
it was like the middle of the night she
was like yeah he's fine he's sleeping i
was whatever a teenager he was like i'm
having this unbelievable sense of dread
next you know in the morning they call
you know your sister passed away he said
since that day
he now just knows how to live with it
but he's that sense of dread has never
left his body wow but he said because of
a twin it's something with twins he was
like something about me as a person died
when my twin died and i feel this dread
wow because i think that there's a part
of me that's genuinely dead like a part
of my soul like he's like i think there
are cells in my body that just don't
light up anymore because of that he's
like it's not that i'm sad because of
course i'm sad i am sad you know i don't
want my siblings to die he's like but
it's not even like oh i can't go on he
goes i'll admit there's days where i
don't even think about her but it's just
dread that it's it's like this weird
feeling i was like wow and that he
started telling me about that and then i
started looking into twins and googling
stuff and i found all these stories
about these twins like there's one story
of us i saw of like a uh uh um
a twin
who
she just got up in the middle of a date
like out of nowhere just got up in the
middle of a date she was like i just
have to leave right now i have to leave
and didn't know what it was like it was
like just a energy taking her to like
where they lived and her sister was like
up in the bed choking on her own vomit
or something like that and she like
saved her life like it's like this weird
connections that twins have that like
they can't really understand and that's
why
in the holocaust
a lot of these german scientists would
experiment on twins like if you were
twins they did all types of like nasty
experiments
to try to figure out like telepathically
and how to use
like how to like see what's going on and
how you're connected without actually
being connected a lot of research for
the cia with because you know like when
um
in the iran hostage crisis and i think
it's 1972 when
uh in the olympics iranians and
americans were held hostage yeah are
argo yeah
yeah the u.s government used telepathics
to try to see what was going on and
psychic abilities and sets of twins to
try to see and use their energy try to
see really and get inside the room in
iran to like uncover negotiation tactics
and what the hostages were saying are
doing and allegedly
that's what worked allegedly
um that's wild isn't it wild what about
what happens if twins one gets heavy
if one swings fast can you google that
one heavy twin
what happens if your twin gets fat
because you don't normally see or
if both twins gain a lot of weight like
that's that's what should happen really
right
yeah like both yeah if you're in sync oh
wow wow look at one fat one
i've never googled this in my life this
is funny
fat twin fit twin they call it
yeah because i think like if you're
twins out there can you email the pod at
heybabypod gmail.com or or instagram
heybaypod or write it in the comments on
the vid or write in the comments on the
video if you're a twin can you tell us
about your experiences because i like to
talk to like twins yeah it's very
fascinating like two identical twins out
there have this connection can you mark
that down so we know next time let's
just like with the taste buds thing yeah
i'd love to
tell us about your twin experiences
anything that's notable
man because it is interesting for one
twin to just get so morbidly obese and
the other one not
it's wild
because she's gonna look at her twin and
be like that's what i would look like if
i was and she looks at her like that's
what i would look like
i think
that's that i mean that's she's she's
got to be three times the size of the
other one right that's that's crazy i
wonder what i wonder what in their in
their psychology is not in sync
where one of them could let
themselves you know be that
undisciplined to get to that size weight
right
i mean you know all things consider was
saying they're so hyper the same i
wonder what
i think what what i'm looking is this
the the twin who got really heavy
on the one side got very depressed
because she didn't have access to hey
babe and the skinny twin was listening
to hey babe every thursday she did she
liked followed and subscribed she like
she followed no press channel she
subscribed to no press she followed on
spotify and she left a rating on itunes
and then she's got skinny and ripped and
she she said this is a free easy way
that i can contribute to a podcast that
i love that will help them and that's
what she did and then the one on the
right who unfortunately lost her way she
probably didn't do any of those things
nope she went on practice she's just
crazy one second
[Laughter]
true
bill we just talked about him on the pod
naturally on the pod naturally because
it genuinely is a product that i swear
to christ i'd use whether or not they
want to sponsor the show i i truly think
it's an amazing invention true that
truett because true true billet really
true because honestly this is one of
those things that that hits our desk the
desk of hay bait it comes across the
desk and i say this is an invention that
is filling a need yes because i've i've
been there if i've been there you've
been there yeah this is one that we
definitely ain't bullshitting yeah this
one genuinely we both use it it saved us
money what it is you sign up for stuff
all the time oh i got this subscription
that's subscription um
this game this streaming service you
know this this online uh you know
periodical everything and anything that
you sign up for and you forget and you
and it's on automatic renewal and you
forget how to you ever tried to go
cancel it's impossible it's like trying
to find the wizards my gym they told me
i got to get a letter from my doctor you
know what i'd excuse my language would i
had to heck with them to heck with them
instead i said oh how about a letter
from my here's my here's his life from
my doctor his name's dr true bill yeah
how much time it is
stupid
i mean we're living in a canceled
culture true bill helps you cancel all
these descriptions true bill's the
cancelled i want to be that's right true
bill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't need want or
simply forgot about gone on average
people save up to seven hundred and
twenty dollars
you know how much hey babe merch you can
buy with 720 you can get all the new
items by the way stop in the merch store
your true build concierge is there when
you need them to cancel unwanted
descriptions so you don't have to there
it is right there that shirt's only
that's just one it's about 25 yeah um
cancel apple tv pick up two t-shirts
that's what it is i love true build
trouble is over two million users and
has helped them save over 100 million
dollars like matthew b says we love
matthew b he says in a matter of seconds
i saved 660 for the year on my direct tv
bill i saved 120 for the year on my
serious xm bill saved 840 a year on my
car insurance that shit's lit it is and
they don't want you know who matthew b
is i'm gonna tell you right now it's
matthew breitman don't fail for
subscription scam start cancelling today
at truebuild.com hey babe go right now
truebuild.com hey babe it can save you
thousands a year
truebill.com
i'm hungry
are you hungry well if there was only a
service that would go to nationwide
chains local chains and even pick up
things like
everyday items from the grocery store
then i would use that service right now
to feed you and also get some toilet
paper milk and bread well unfortunately
sal we're living in a world where there
isn't that service there's not
is there i think there is now wait a
second it's called doordash babe there's
a service called doordash that'll get me
anything i want to get me anything from
paper towels to cheeseburgers to almond
milk every escargot everything you just
said think about a restaurant clear
across the other end of the island that
you can't get to but you want right now
doordash will have that food to you
piping hot in under 30 minutes or you
won't have to company i love the united
states of america because they have
doordash
i'm telling you doordash has got over
300 thousand partners you can support
your neighborhood go-to's you can even
get your favorite national restaurants
like pop-ups chipotles and cheesecake
factory oh god ordering's easy i was
gonna read the cheesecake factory
menu but instead i read the iliad
items they say items will be left safely
outside your door when you choose
contact this contactless delivery
drop-off well i'll tell you what
doordash i don't want to be left outside
because i love you service so much i'll
eat the delivery man wow
act now for a limited time our listeners
can get 25 off and zero delivery fees on
their first order of 15 bucks or more
when you download the door dash app and
enter code hey babe that's 25 off up to
10 beans and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
code hey babe don't forget that's code
hey babe for 25 off your first order
with doordash subject to change terms
um
so
so yeah it's interesting do you do you
ever could go back to the twitter were a
twin or had a twin i always wondered
what it'd be like to have a brother
now because she's just got sisters and
you but you don't have any i'm only
child right
it's weird to be honest can you go back
to the twin facts that you had you know
that's why i think i have two kids
because i think i always felt like
i think i always felt like being an only
child growing up an only child like how
sad it was that i was like i don't want
my children did you feel sad or did you
also just get all the attention
no but i always felt like rosie used to
play in a ditch i always felt i always
felt i wish you would end up dead in a
ditch i always felt i always felt
like embarrassed that i was an only
child anytime i tell someone i'm only a
child i feel embarrassed by it because i
feel like people always will say oh you
must be spoiled you must have had all
the attention your my life must have
been easy all these things i'm like i
almost never tell people i'm an only
child as a matter of fact there's been
many times even on syndra i've just made
up the fact that i have a sister right
but i don't
because because i
i've always felt that and i felt like
with my child my you know i had my first
daughter i was like
you know even though she has a a half
brother
who she's very close with i was like i
feel though like
biologically
i would sit there and be like
you know i'm the i'm an only child
because i grew up in the same house my
cousin my first cousin lived with me
in the same house on the on the bottom
floor so she was in effect like a sister
yeah but she had half brothers and
sisters so she really was an only child
okay you have half brothers and sisters
you're not an only child do you wish
you had siblings yeah but i don't know
but people say oh if you wish you had
siblings you would wish you're an only
child i'm like i don't know because
being an only child
you know it's kind of like
it's almost like you think it's like all
the hours spent indoors when you weren't
allowed to see your friends
i was probably playing with my siblings
yeah i mean my my younger sis is way
younger my i have a sister three years
younger that we really kind of grew up
kind of close step to each other so
all that time that we would like you you
just had that time to yourself
yeah my mother would make me recite the
state capitals and read stuff from the
encyclopedia and that's why you know all
that now that's why i know a lot of
people see i don't know any of that
because yeah
but you know a lot about women's fashion
i do know a lot about women's rights you
don't you do you see so it all works out
um speaking of women's fashion you know
what i really really really really
really want i don't know why i've been
thinking about it a good raincoat
i i swear to god i'm not kidding for
some reason right before you said it i
thought of a couple things and that was
one of them i don't know why what oh
maybe are they wearing raincoats no
maybe i don't know i thought of it you
know i had identical twins you know i
have two raincoats and i almost bought a
third what are they less what a length
75 of the way down because that's what i
want i do i don't want a short one i
don't want my ass sticking out i have
one that's three quarter length wow
it's beautiful i got it i got a raincoat
for you i got something you're going to
love
i'll tell you give it to me no i i i no
one get it for me i know one that you
would like
yeah yeah yeah did you ever hear the
company called rain
they make they make a really cool jack
really cool only raincoats yeah i think
so yeah
all different colors i have
something from like a pendleton i have
the classic it's you know the wax cot
the wax material it's like
it's like wax cotton a wax cotton it's
in bags and coats it's like wax okay so
there's a wax in it it's like i know
what wax is it feels like it's it's soft
but it feels like wax okay you you you
just felt it before i have that as a
yellow raincoat three-quarter length so
it's like it's even like the yet like a
classic yellow
do you ever wear a yellow raincoat i do
you've worn it out no it's not like you
think it's not like the old shiny
raincoat you ever worn a raincoat not in
the rain
i did because i also have another north
face that's an all-weather raincoat
that's not a three-quarter that can
double as a jacket you know when you
need it interesting interesting you know
you want to get a raincoat you want to
get caught in the rain after that yeah
you want to and guess what i did guess
what i finally did you ready for this i
gave to the salvation army and different
donation boxes around staten island that
i could find ninety nine zero percent of
my wardrobe away gone done i got four
pairs of lululemon pants a few of these
robux t-shirts i swear to god some of
the hay bay merch i got a couple of
jackets the rest gone i just you did a
purge i threw it in black garbage bags
and sal
i feel like this is the thing i don't
worry about a thing don't you worry
about that
gave it all away i can't tell you
how cathartic it is
and how much walking into my closet and
just not having
a mess of things and not even when
things were nicely folded and looked all
nice just not seeing clutter it opens up
like my soul free like i felt like i
feel like a different human being i
don't worry about anything i'll take
this shirt i'll throw it right on the
floor and there's only a couple of items
on the floor there's no i don't live
with a mess i love it i don't have a
mess i must have given away i'm not
lying i must have given away
easily ten thousand dollars worth of
clothes i've accumulated over the course
of let's say the last five years which
isn't really that much money i mean
right right ten thousand dollars over
five years is like i mean what are you
[ __ ] yeah what are you spending a
couple of grand a year yeah one close
that's like
20 a day or something right all right
so so so
how did you decide what would go what
wouldn't go the only things i kept were
my lululemon pants because they're and
the reason why i like them so much is
because they are um
durable and versatile versatile i can
wear them to exercise or like here's you
know how many you know what i've been
doing lately is i've been going i i
don't know why i've been huge huh
on stage but i've been exercising in the
morning in these lululemon pants say or
these athleisure pants i don't want to
give them too much free promo these
athleisure pants i would be exercising
them lulu if you're watching and we know
you are just throw us free merch give us
do the right thing do the right thing um
i'll shower at the gym and then put
these pants back on and just bring one
t-shirt so i bring a small book bag put
just a t-shirt in there
keep the same pants because even when
you sweat these they never smell and
they never really get away with your
wicking they're moisture wicking
and i just so i kept that and i kept a
couple of these types of shirts like
this that are again versatile and and
you don't feel like you need to go
shopping for clothes you just love the
limited yes it's like it's like what we
have now it's streaming there's too many
options you get flustered you don't know
what to do you don't watch anything yeah
yeah that's how i i'm where you are i
have i have hundreds i might have 500
t-shirts
yeah 500 i'm not joking and do you ever
feel like you want to get rid of him
yes but why don't you what's your
thoughts it's weird
you know
like
i'll throw out ones i don't like but if
i still like it i'm like
i'll rifle through it or i don't want to
like are you about to sneeze i was going
to sneeze i could feel it yeah twins
yeah were you going to sneeze i felt
that you were going to sneeze my heart
would flurry that's what it is
i don't want to lose like because i go
up a little bit one will get tight but
i'm like i love that shirt and i look
forward to wearing it again when i go
down and wait a little bit like so i
just kind of keep everything yeah see i
used to think like that and i think that
that's a fine way of thinking but i'm
just telling you i don't i push it i
just feel i can't explain it about it
it's just because you don't really need
actually anything as a matter of fact
buying all these like clothes and having
all these wearing all these different
outfits like to even the kings and
queens of old of the old world would be
like why are you doing that like it says
you wear the same thing every week just
wash it out like now people are like oh
you wore that shirt wednesday like if
you said that to the king of france you
said it to the sun
one of the highest nobles of fashion
it's supposed to re-went for a side
they'd be like yeah why would i what am
i it'd be like buying it being in a new
house every week to them they'd be like
why would you do that right you buy
clothes you wash them what what's wrong
with it one time damon dash was on conan
okay and i remember damon's shout out
rockefeller rockefeller yeah that's
where he was that's i don't know what
he's doing now and i remember he said
he said to conan
i've never worn
the same thing twice
and conan was like what and he goes i
own a clothing company i don't need to
he goes i wear something once and i
donate it he's like i've never ever worn
the same thing two times see that i
respect because he donates it
i understand that it's i understand that
there's no point in it i get it how it
might be don't you like to break a shirt
or a pair of pants in that i see but i
do like that he wears it and at least
donates it i think that's noble of him
if he was just wearing it and be like oh
i throw it away or i just leave it there
whatever i mean because there are people
that throw away clothes i i had to give
mine away you got to give him one i'm
always saying he had a friend who would
take his clothes on the road with him
and leave the suitcase there oh joe got
him yeah and he would leave it for what
like the staff no he would just no like
he would he would just throw clothes
away
he'd be like ah that's probably
i never seen anything like it he'd go
like ah this would be the last time i'm
wearing this tonight
and then i'm like what and then like we
would get on stage we'd get on stage and
he would take it off and put in the
garbage
he was just throwing oh he'd throw it
into the crowd or something he'd just be
shirtless yeah he just oh he'd just be
like uh i don't want these anymore and
he just leave close like he just was
like he actually wears clothes to a
point and then says i don't want these
clothes anymore and then he gets me i
wear clothes until they either fall
apart don't fit or go out as fashion
right like you know i mean i i'm not
gonna take my clothes that fit and be
like i'm throwing this away
yeah i feel like well pimp your
fashionista what do you feel about
clothes do you care about them
no you you like to dress nice yeah but
they just disappear after a few years
yeah is your is your apartment because
oh by the way i went to pimp's apartment
i saw what casa de homeless pimp okay
great place by the way hold on everybody
yeah
i mean can we even call him homeless
pimp anymore he has a home
he's home pimp he's home pimp
home i went to home pimp you were inside
yes
i was inside home pimp's house see
that's his apartment i was sitting on
his little pink couch
um
am i starting to look a little beefy sal
in a good way same shirt yeah
oh you ever you ever you ever all of a
sudden article clothing you love is
missing and you'll never see it again
ever and you don't know where it went
that happened to me like in my life like
with like like a couple dozen things
like i have a shirt i wore all the time
i'll see it one time in a photo i'll go
i've never given that shirt away i don't
know where that shirt is that shirt is
gone gone gone did that never happen to
you no
well you had a shirt or a pair of pants
or article clothing and then it one day
you couldn't find it and you never found
it again
you never lost clothes or not that i can
recall
all right i can't recall
but what fascinating what i will tell
you though is if if the people someone
listening out there if you feel
like i'm telling you if you've tried
everything to relieve stress to just
feel like if you got that feeling where
like the world's caving in on me blah
blah blah and you tried everything else
try to get rid of your clothes and live
in a
not um not messy fully minimalist fully
minimalistic
two pairs of pants a pair of shorts or
just shirt whatever the hell james
altucher do you know james altucher
this podcast sponsored by two words
better help i love it
because you know what it is babe is
there's some times where like i just
have a lot on my mind
i feel stressed out i feel burnt out i
don't know where to turn i'm like 247
365. that's what i like about betterhelp
i don't have to wait for the office to
open the office is always open
you're right which was which is what i
like virtual online all the time you get
connected with a therapist online
virtually in under two days 48 hours and
you could speak to them you don't now
you don't have to leave your house to go
to therapy i don't don't even have to
turn on your camera do you know me you
don't want to i have to do you know many
times
i've been cheaper i've literally
gotten
problems off my chest to my counter that
have helped me so much of my life and
i've been but naked while i'm doing it
yeah butt naked i got my open butthole
on my couch yeah and i'm purging my
emotions and it's helpful and beneficial
and i have my camera off and the
therapist kindness counselor has
i'm telling him i'm butt naked he says
do it makes you feel comfortable right
and that's and that's and that's what
better helps it you can never get that
anywhere else now if you guys want a
discount which i know that you do
because we all do go to betterhelp.com
hey babe that's better h-e-l-p dot com
slash hey babe gonna get 10 off the
first month
sunglasses season is here and let me
tell you babe there's no better option
than our friends at shady rays there
ain't nothing shady about shady ray's
independent sunglass company that offers
a world-class product that's just as
good as any expensive pair we've ever
freaking worn okay durable frames
extremely clear polarized lenses they're
they got polarized lenses not polarized
political opinions which i like they're
great for outdoor adventures if you
don't love them you can exchange for a
new pair or return them for free within
30 days so there's genuinely no risk for
you at all you return them for free if
you don't like them that's no risk at
all when you shop with shady rays their
team always has you back and they've
donated over 20 million um uh meals
to fight hunger in america which i love
this i'm telling you and they're dope
this sunglass company this is it for you
exclusively for our listeners shady
raise is giving out their best deal of
the season go to
shadyraise.com and use code hey babe for
50 off plus two pairs of polarized
sunglasses that's
shadyraise.com s-h-a-d-y-r-a-y-s
dot com code hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e
50 off plus two pairs of polarized
sunglasses try for yourself the shades
rated five stars by over two hundred
thousand people
james altucher do you know james
altucher he's a co-owner of stand-up new
york comedy club yeah if you look him up
i think he was like tony robbins like
finance guy he was like one of the first
millionaires of bitcoin is he the guy
that said something that about new york
you are dead in the people yeah
so he told me once
the happiest he ever was in his life
okay you know this guy is worth at one
point was worth 55 million dollars okay
more probably he said the happiest he
was in his life is when he was living
what he would do with his family with
his wife and two kids rather than i know
this is extreme but just show you rather
than mountain dew so is mountain yeah
shadow mandu rather than living in uh
like this over cluttered house and
getting furniture what he would do is
live in an airbnb for three months in
the same area because he wanted his kids
to go to the same school each one of
them he'd live in the airbnb so he's not
buying any furniture he's using other
people's furniture that was already
furnished airbnb
you know live normally
get you know he had money so he would
get a house a five-bedroom house or
whatever it may be each member of his
family him his wife and i believe he had
three kids would each i'll be allowed a
suitcase full of clothing okay
that's what they had
for their life is a suitcase full of
they won't be properly well fed them go
on vacations and live normally except
they're not buying any stuff for the
house furnitures they're not over
consuming they're just living with
what's there and the suitcase and if
they wanted a new article of clothing
they were allowed to buy them at will
however they would have to remove an
article of clothing from the suitcase
okay so you could buy something one for
one exchange but it would need to be
replaced and he said that was by far by
far the happiest his family ever was as
soon as they stopped living that
lifestyle you have options in front of
you divorced
really divorced done
broken up so that's the secret to a
happy marriage a suitcase full of
clothes full of clothes you got to live
like you're about to get thrown out
do you know that i this is true
i have lost clothing i i'm thinking of
one shirt in particular right now right
but i've lost clothing and do you know
that i spend time in my life thinking
about where it may be and the life it
has now
i think about a shirt that i lost it was
a maroon shirt it was like velour with
white and gray stripes on both arms with
a v-neck and i and this is only one of
dozens and i've i've spent time in my
life being like
where could i have lost it and what was
the journey like like like it's final
like an american tale like it just went
on a journey after me the shirt and
somebody found it at somebody's house
and maybe they donated or somebody just
said i'm taking this and they wore it
and what what where that shirt went in
his travels and what it saw after it
left my body
i think about that you think about that
yeah is that weird no it is because you
do feel weird you don't is that weird i
like daydream about the shirt on
somebody else like
in a riverboat somewhere and i don't
know i just think like what does this
thing seem after me whose life is it a
part of now you do face something
no because you do have a connection with
clothes like jasmine we were in puerto
rico at moto in san juan the fort yeah
she came out it says all over it says
all over this fort watch out for loose
articles clothing that especially hats
it will blow off your head she goes up
there with the coachella hat goes up for
a picture when mine augusta wind blows
the hat right off the fort run to the
atlantic ocean right i think about where
that hat is yeah in the atlantic ocean i
think about that weekly yeah and most
likely
i never put that hat on my head right
most likely it's not in the same spot
it's probably always on the move
right
oh yeah right it's a hat i mean the
current's got to be taking that thing it
has to eventually maybe eventually wash
up somewhere well i told you i told you
the story i know i said to the voice i
know he said on the pond when i was in
seattle i saw that homeless guy push
that guy off the his bike and then take
the bike and he rode past he was wearing
a hey babe shirt yes yeah i mean it's
yes
it was one of those things where i
thought is that's my imagination how
could this be real but it's like no it's
somebody else
somebody from seattle or whatever that
must have just somehow and they and they
they discarded our they discarded our
merch immediately and gave it to a
homeless shelter that is that is a funny
wound up on a
where do we sell it uh uniontown
uh
you saw that did you did you lose your
mind lost my mind i was like am i am i
in edibles right but i know i know what
i saw do you know do you think do you
know okay you know what i think might
feel as good as what you just said you
know what i think might lift my spirits
and free me
sorry there's a ghost i don't know if
you're turning this in the back uh
do you know what do you know what i
think would be amazing could did you
have a daydream about getting down to
zero emails
buddy let me tell you something for me i
heard if they call it something like
how many emails do you have unopened
right now if you have to guess open your
phone and tell open your phone and tell
me the real number right now place your
bets who has more
unopened emails right now on their phone
me or so i don't want to tell you the
real number and then you're going to
wait is how do you know what's unopened
and what's not like the thing it'll say
there's a number right now i'm looking
like that no no look put your app like
go to like just where the app is
mailboxes no but go to like the home
screen oh oh oh oh oh like that no i i i
take that off oh you don't have that i
can't live like that okay so go to i'll
do it for text but i don't do the little
red let me see if the red number will be
thousands every day
yes all in boxes and go to all inboxes
the same number do you want me to add
them up
no just go to all inboxes at the top
that should be the
okay okay okay what's yours twenty one
thousand two ninety three fifty thousand
three seventy four you're kidding me
where
oh
oh my god
dude i thought i was drowning in emails
you have two one and a half times the
email 50
374. one of them's from the new york
city ferry there's a service advisory
all around for independence day what why
do you have no but you know everyone
from new york mets helped send our mets
to l.a you have they can't this team
can't afford to know their own games
against the dodgers you have to
unsubscribe to a lot of stuff that's how
i help myself because they'll send you
20 emails a week from one place i went
on an unsubscribing spree it was like it
was like jim carrey and [ __ ] intruder
what's his name tell the truth true lie
a liar was just like telling her i just
went i just went nuts i was like i you
know what i did what's that thing that
helps you unsubscribe from everything
true bill i true build them i went
through it when i opened it i go to my
emails and drew bill on subscribe i
don't know about that that's like that
seems like it's back back that's not
gonna work see i don't care about the
email i don't care about the emails the
texts i can't handle the text i have to
open up all my texts
what do you think
do you think that you could delete
in one swoop to 50 000
and then be see the reason i you can't
do it once it gets too far right there
are emails i need as reference points
for things that contain information or
that i just want for nostalgia purposes
although that's why so i can't go
through and just delete them all because
then i'll i know i'll i'm deleting
history i have emails for 20 years in
here you know what i mean but but maybe
not but like but you know what i mean
you can't just delete them all so what
are we to do
i read this there's blogs and websites
that will help you get down to like like
you did with the clothes to like a few
emails only i'm telling you ever since i
threw on half my not 90 of my wardrobe
i don't even if you told me there's an
email in there
from
you know
steven spielberg that i'm going to be in
the next jurassic park
and i deleted it and all i had to do was
reply yes to this email and i would be
the new chris whatever the hell his name
is who's the leader jurassic park
pratt yeah
i
would if you said but
it could be in there could not be but if
you delete them you'll never know i
would just delete them and never know or
never care so right now because i think
i'll just get in the next thing would
you like go in and just
on a mailbox and just hit swipe and
delete like thousands in one shot but
can you even do that
i don't know i don't even think you can
do that
if there was a button to do that i'd do
that i can't because i live in fear so i
would i would hate the fact that i
erased something that one day could come
back to buy me in the ass sal i'm
telling you what i did was i went into
that goddamn closet i got five black
garbage bags that's what i thought i
need
20 black garbage bags later i felt like
a new person i was just throwing [ __ ] in
the only things i kept were the
athleisure stuff and stuff that like my
daughters got me like you know dad's
shirts on father's day or like things
like that like oh you know we bought
this on a trip little mementos but even
that i was able to fit in uh you know
like a like a relatively small box and i
just put it in the basement yeah so it's
so funny because what is even that for
which and i'm i'm saying i get attached
to stuff i usually do this purge like as
an exercise like maybe once a year and
it's maybe two four two or three bags
but it's nowhere near the dent of what i
would throw away if i could do that i
could imagine how liberating it is so
liberating and the stuff even holding on
to the stuff the mementos like that is
just like just in case like you know my
kid wants to talk about when my kids are
18 if they're like yeah throw away the
father's day shirts i'll [ __ ] throw
them right off the verrazano bridge
right off i'm just don't care you won't
care but i'm stopping traffic you don't
understand there's shirts that i bought
two weeks ago this shirt remember the
shirts that i said i bought with emilio
that were like 300 and i hate it i hate
the way they look at the way it feel
right in the bag i'm giving i gave them
to a kid in salvation army right you
know someone there's someone robbing
someone's bike wearing that shirt right
now robin wearing that shirt right now i
don't care at all
the socks the underwear i threw it away
i i well i not throw it away i gave it
to someone right that needs it more than
me right i should do a whole pass
do it yeah it only took an hour it took
an hour i was sweating that would take
me a weekend
because no it would take you a weekend
because you're you you're you're close
to thinking you're making so saying i'll
look at a shirt and remember all the
good times i had with it and then i'll
put it in a pile right i could be like
this is how i do it i go
no way i know i could give this away
this pile and there's no way anywhere in
three weeks gone
i know that run away in three weeks
that's tough fun right out the window
that's amazing it's probably the right
thing to do but it's tough i have shirts
my oldest shirt is from june uh from
june
1989. did you still actively wear no
but it was the first concert i went to
and so i said don't throw that out why
did you put that in the frame yeah i'm
gonna actually actually put that it's a
poison t-shirt and i just met brett
michaels and i'm gonna have him sign it
and put in the frame have him son so
imagine he says no
he better say yes
pete alonso the first baseman washington
michaels
you better sign it or i'm going to give
you some sweet chin music or that's
shawn michaels that's sean michaels it'd
be funny if brett michaels gave you
sweet chin music
pete alonzo pete alonzo the first
baseman in the new york mets gave me a
bathrobe and he signed it okay and he
signed it and my family my daughter
loves robes has been wearing this pete
alonso bathrobe and then because she saw
pete alonso's name signed on it she
thought i did that and it was a bathrobe
she could
make of she drew pictures all over it
with the marker so now i can't even sell
the pete alonso signed bathrobe if he
goes to the hall of fame for real money
yeah but you can
cause it might
delilah my daughter's gonna have to get
real famous she's gonna have to be the
next nelson rockwell
nelson rockwell what is it the rockwell
paintings uh are we talking about
nelson
didn't you say it's nelson rockefeller
no no norman roberts
look here's what i do
i know i want to give this away uh no
way i'm keeping it and then there's the
middle pile and the middle pile i look
at it and i say it's the biggest pile i
say oh man this was with me when i saw
this concert or oh i remember where i
wore this on this vacation or hey you
know what
i lose five pounds that's gonna fit
great again or whatever it is and then i
go or someone gave me this like this was
a gift from my mom whatever and i put it
in that pile and then i get attached to
that [ __ ] and i can't get rid of it
do you
delete text because i'm i'm left in the
text department i'm just texting
why i'm kidding
i said depends whose text then i looked
deeply into the camera do you do you
remember when we had like the flips you
used to delete them you had only a
certain amount of room you have to
delete now you go from phone to phone
you port them all over and now again i
use them as a reference point so like if
i had to like oh i haven't seen this guy
i'll scroll back three years and be like
or look his name up or you know and then
look at the text and i go to the text
i've gotten i've gotten
texas saved my ass old texts i had
construction being done and i asked them
to do a certain thing and it was as
black and white as possible i laid it
all out i told them why i wanted to be
this way everything i could think of
right so here comes the day they're
doing the construction something tells
me to just go over there and double
check everything because they started
and they were like 20 into the job
would you know that everything i told
them they would they they got it wrong
they ordered the wrong things
that i needed and i was like what are
you doing this isn't what i ordered and
they're like yes it is and i went back
like six eight months ago to a thing and
i pulled up the exchange between me and
that person and i was like look at this
if i would have deleted that text i
would have been done did they say when
you showed them the text they were like
i am you are 100 right i am sorry and i
will fix it immediately isn't it great
when people do that when people just
give them all the credit in the world
how great is that because so many people
just won't do that yeah it's like if you
prove what he may not have if i didn't
have that text no no he definitely
wouldn't yeah he definitely would've but
i give all the credit in the world well
he was like you're right i'm wrong it'll
be fixed immediately so that was nice
and he fixed it yes
great and it was the tune of
it would have been thousands and
thousands and thousands of dollars
that it would have cost me that you got
back because she saved the text save the
text well yeah saving text
is fine but at one point like i've been
saving them now
what's the last date of your the first
text what's what's the oldest text you
have in here oldest text
okay
my oldest text is i remember this it's
when i switched from android to iphone
okay i was at the
netflix is it not that netflix is a joke
what was the one they were doing the the
san francisco comedy festival every year
the big one
it was in san francisco fest clusterfest
i was at the clusterfest uh festival in
july july 3rd 2017 and my phone you
still have the same phone from 2017 no
it was when i switched my phone broke on
that trip and i needed a phone so in san
fran i went to the store and i said i'm
switching to an iphone i had android my
whole life up to that and i switched to
iphone and that is when i got my first
iphone i've had iphone ever since so the
text i've never raced text since that
day oh you get that like when i get a
new phone my text how do you get your
text over it's your old phone very very
simple you just check you just check the
text and it'll port over really just
like you save emails apps or any
information like my last text my first
text from this phone is from june 28th
2021.
no because you just didn't check the box
to port it over
so i have but because my
my old phone wouldn't even turn on
but i think if your old phone had that
checked it would be backing up to the
cloud all the time so that when you got
a new phone
it would you'd have everything from when
that phone died which uh which kind of
would be everything because once that
phone died you weren't getting texts but
if it's not on your phone can it still
be on the icloud like can my text will
be on the icloud even though not on my
phone yes
if if you were backing them up and how
would i be backing them up from i guess
via icloud it doesn't automatically do
it if it's checked it does
what do you mean checked
in other words if you said to your phone
every night back up all my [ __ ] to the
to the cloud it will do that
automatically every night no matter what
i have to press a button on my phone for
that to be done i believe you have to
choose that or make sure it's chosen
uh it might be on or i don't know but
then when you get that phone everything
well you got all your emails right you
got all your apps you got all your
contacts it's just like the contacts
same exact thing the very first text
from this phone yeah on june 28 2021
said hey brother if you're in nyc would
love for you to be a guest on my podcast
hey babe next week if you have time and
are interested if not all good stay well
who was that too
fat joe
no there was zero response wow joe what
are you gonna text me right now just
checking back in on this
uh
mine was june 28 2017
and it was trying to get my family
together to
to hang out
did they hang out
uh
yes
yes we hung out on sunday
yeah
let me let me get the next one oh the
next one is
anything juicy the next one is a
comedian group chat
that i'm not a part of one one um one
number is gone so they i don't know who
that number is anymore
but it was gone but not forgotten or
they are forgotten
i'm forgotten
it was with roy wood colin joe steve
byrne and an unidentified number that's
a fun group chat i don't know that's a
really fun group on chat unidentified
spun look oh look at this
the third one in this might be fun
gino from gino's cheese sticks
wow
what'd he say
he said he retexted me hey sal what's up
just got down to the short turn on tv
and there you are shouting out bingo on
tv it was so funny how are things hope
to see you soon let's chat take care
gino what'd you respond hey buddy hope
you're well i'm okay same old just busy
with working on the road a lot planning
a vacation which can't come soon enough
how are you
how are you
what'd he say what'd he say hey buddy
work has been crazy i opened the new
retail store that has taken every out to
me i know the feeling of needing
vacation i was in la for two days flying
home now hope to see you soon in philly
catch up soon give me a call
next one theo vaughn
wow
theovon adam ray and chris milhouse
you're on a lot of comedian group texts
this was i was doing a show at the house
of blues
and what city
uh this was house of blues
i think it was san diego house of blues
cleveland i saw hansen perform um-bop
when they were in their
late 20s
and i was in cleveland cross-treated
hilarities
you saw them i saw them performing
i'm going to tell you where this is
house of blues
and they came they came and they were on
the show they killed
they killed yeah
they killed that was before i guess
what year is this this was 2017. what a
good year 2017 was i think it was i i've
said this before i think it was my best
year best year of your life it was one
of my best years 2019 2017
house of blues boss
no
i don't i think it was i think it was in
san diego hospitals 2017 you were 40
yeah
until until november so right this point
i was exactly 40. 4-0 that's good
i feel like people like their 40s the
best look who's on this show let's see
milhouse hosted then it was adam ray
theo vaughn and tommy jonigan and me
that's a good show tommy john again is
so he doesn't do comedy anything anymore
that much he doesn't you stand up
anymore does he do it just right i know
he he's writing for he's a big writer
big writer for tv has a pod shout out
tommy john again he's a great stand-up
tommy john again he was one of my
favorites yeah i i think he is so damn
funny i was so happy to make friends and
that he came do you think you could ever
stop or ever will stop doing stand up
uh how could you see a world where you
just don't do it anymore
i
don't see it i don't see it
i just feel like
even if i'm not doing it
how we do it now there's no way i won't
get up every few weeks and just do it
just do it yeah there's no there's no
just it's fun
especially when i'm like all right i'm
not gonna do the road like this anymore
but i'm but i'm home maybe i'm retired
maybe i'm like you know just maybe i'm
working on something but i'm just going
for fun to the city that you know i mean
yeah i could picture still doing it a
couple nights a week
especially if i'm like retired i would
want to do it two or three nights a week
um speaking of uh retiring and and and
comedy clubs i know this has nothing to
do with anything but that's what the
show is have you ever been to the
restaurant belatos in new york city on
houston street amelia's bolada amilos
bolados babe bro babe have i been there
i'm on the wall babe
we have i'm on the wall babe and i
signed the wall
where's your picture on the wall
uh
it's if you walk in it's you know it's
long yeah first is the first front
seating and then you know there's back
seating yeah there's another place yeah
it's in the front on the right about
three quarters of the way back i i've
been going to that restaurant every week
i love how did you find out about this
my friend one of my neighbors who i
lived on staten island was born and
raised in little italy knew about
bolados for years in the middle of a
little italy little did we know he's got
two middlemen who didn't do diddly
that's twins that's fat joe and big pun
there you go deep in yeah bellato's i he
told me about it i went in there
balls blown off best chicken collards
in my life
chef wayne oh anthony great kid handsome
devil jacked goes to the works out at
the gym down the street on mulberry
street called uh nyc gym great jim um
it is the best food i think personally
italian sit down style red sauce place
in new york city personally that that's
my i i i want to say that i personally
think that it's in the conversation and
it's a place that i always refer people
to when they want a restaurant or an
especially italian one and they don't
want like the same old like you know the
ones everyone knows not that emilio's it
doesn't have a name for itself but you
know you say something like uh carbon or
something yeah exactly like that or
what's the other one uh anyway there's a
there's a handful of them uh my the
first time i went my my uh
my my now manager
we had one of our first meetings there
what year 2017 no no it was like 10
years ago you went to you've been going
to blottos for years he introduced you
to it you went to way before people knew
about it well i don't know if they know
everybody's known about it for a while
he said look he goes i'll take you to my
favorite italian spot you know it's it's
great he's like it's like people
it's like people talk about rayo's this
place is like you can get into it and
it's just as good right
and uh yeah he took me there and we
loved it and i've been going there for
10 years tell me how often when's the
last time you'd have been a bellator the
last time i've been at bellato's i i
want to say it has probably had well it
was before pandemic this wednesday do
you want to go with me
at nine o'clock in tomorrow tomorrow you
want to go i actually may because i'm
headlining new york comedy club be able
to i'm doing like a new job like i'm
doing it's called i have nothing where
it's just like me trying to work out my
new hour it's like a little residency
and every wednesday i'm going to be
doing a show what's up have a new hour
already no no it's called i have nothing
because it's it's i have nothing so i
mean we're working out what work out
even any part of what will be the new
hour exactly not an hour
it's five bucks for the special to get
in and it's just like you're kind of i'm
working i need a place yeah to run the
hour this is the place i love it seven
o'clock
i'd like to do that 8 30 and
reservations belongs nine you want to
come
um yes you don't have to you don't have
to go no no so so i'm going to the
yankee game at one okay you can't go to
that i can't go yeah so i'm going to the
end one i'm not i'm not looking at
taiwan on there i think everybody else
is probably going to be but that'll be
over by what 4 30 4 30. and then i have
to understand if i'm coming back here or
if that crowd is moving into the city
and if i find myself in the city after
that game i will take you up on it
yeah we're going to go we're going to do
it i'll take you up on it so what so
guys if you want to see hang out me and
sal wednesday june 29th
will be there at nine o'clock this has
been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your
babe feelings babe hey